hey what's up guys mkbhd and this is the
Samsung Galaxy Note 2 now Samsung has
learned a lot from the success of the
galaxy s3 people love that phone so they
started to take some design ideas from
it and bring it to other products so
they shrunk one down and made a Galaxy
s3 mini and they stretched one out and
here we have the Galaxy Note 2 but this
Note 2 is a little bit better than just
a supercharged Galaxy s3 so we'll take a
look and see all the reasons why that is
now but first of all the size let's make
a scale this is the Galaxy Nexus a phone
that people originally thought was
really big just borderline too big four
point six five inch display then another
giant came along in a similar footprint
that four point eight inch Galaxy s3
both of these phones were and still are
considered huge phones and then there's
the Galaxy Note a 5.5 inch behemoth of a
display easily the largest of the smart
phones out there right now and you can
see if the body of the galaxy s3 can
almost fit in the screen of the note
itself it's that spacious a lot of
people seem to think it's too close to a
tablet size but trust me it comes
nowhere near the smallest of the Android
tablets out there and what's neat is all
these displays are the same 1280 by 720
resolution and because of the same
resolution you don't actually see more
content when you're for example looking
at a webpage but you do see the same
content bigger on the note which helps
with reading so some content you just
can't read it's too small when you're
zoomed all the way out on the galaxy s3
but you look at it on the note and you
can actually pretty much read it no
problem oh and the note display also is
not pentile so that's also a plus but
you can't really talk much about this
hardware without comparing it to that
galaxy s3 so I'll link my full galaxy s3
review down below the like button on
this video so you can get a better look
at that but in terms of comparison these
guys are rocking very similar exteriors
so the note 2 has the camera on the
flash both in the same spot up at the
top of the phone but it moves the
speaker down to the bottom and they have
a very similar slicked-back design we of
course both have the white versions here
and they look look
very similar you can see that the design
elements from the galaxy s3 have moved
up to the galaxy notes size they are
also rocking the exact same imaging
hardware so the photo and video quality
1080p video is exactly the same both
look very very good obviously the
biggest difference between the galaxy s3
and the note 2 is that screen size and
you can call me freak or whatever but I
can touch all four corners of the galaxy
s3 is four point eight inch display no
problem at all making it a one-handed
device you can type everything you can
use the whole thing one-handed the note
2 on the other hand is a guaranteed 2
handed device for everyone except maybe
I don't know yeah Ming you can't touch
all four corners with one hand but it
makes for very easy two handed operation
especially when typing on that Samsung
keyboard there are some settings just on
the note 2 from Samsung to make it
easier for one-handed use to turn on and
basically use the phone with one hand
which basically just shrinks things down
and moves them a little bit to one side
of the screen so with the calculator
here for example you can use it with
your left hand on the left hand side if
you're a lefty or on the right hand side
with your right hand if you're a righty
and that's nifty now the one thing about
the hardware is and I don't know if it's
just me or if it's just a my note but
the note 2 rocks when you press the
right hand side of it it rocks back and
forth that's where the stylus sits so I
don't know if you know maybe the stylus
is lighter than the rest of the body or
if it's actually lopsided but it's
really annoying when I'm trying to type
on a flat surface and it keeps bouncing
over to the right very nice but I felt
the need to mention that but anyway not
only am i a fan of the note 2's
quad-core processor and 2 gigs of ram
and LTE but software is pretty great too
it runs Android 4.1.1 jelly bean which
is the latest version out right now and
on top of that is a little bit of
TouchWiz now you guys know that I prefer
stock Android of the Nexus line any day
of the week but with the screen size
like this you kind of do need some
adjustments to be made and you know you
get some different looks some
pre-installed apps and you know the
messy ugly calendar app and the dreaded
s voice is still present but you also
get things like Google now and Android
4.1 jelly beans
mandible notifications which I love so
much and you get a little nifty slide to
open apps from the lockscreen shortcuts
and you can pick which apps go there so
even this wicked multitasking mode that
lets you use two apps at once with half
the screen for each app all this stuff
you get is a lot better than the
previous versions and this is way more
responsive by the way than the first
time they tried this they tried this on
a 10.1 inch tablet it was awful
so I guess that shows off the note twos
power it's not even like I use this
feature a lot but when I do holy hell it
is useful I mean you can watch a video
and fact check at the same time or you
could use Facebook and Google Plus at
the same time whatever you want to do it
is fast and yes that is because this
Note 2 is a powerhouse I never really
put a lot of weight on benchmarks you
guys know that and I might do a video
about why in the near future but I ran a
quick quadrant standard benchmark to see
how it compares to other Android devices
to see if that quad-core and two gigs of
ram held up and of course that combo did
turn out on top but in the end it's
really more about the experience that
these high-performance internals can
deliver and boy do they deliver
real-world performance here is a 10 out
of 10 this is half the hardware and half
jelly bean and project butter at work
here but everything everything is
buttery smooth and I love it gaming on
this huge display is really fun whatever
game you're playing whether you're
slicing and dicing fruit in landscape
mode like a boss or outrunning some
zombies in portrait mode everything
happens so smooth on this massive
display that it's really refreshing and
pleasing to see for someone who's been
using Android Sense Eclair like me and
even if you're not gaming regular
performance in apps that you use
everyday is stellar it's almost like you
don't even notice that there could ever
be any hang-ups they just don't happen
and I never ever ever ever thought I
would say this ever but I kind of like
the stylus and and don't worry you don't
have to like it too you don't you don't
even have to use a stylus it's just in
addition to the phone but to me it feels
like a part of the experience of using
this phone especially a phone this
you about the stylus and it's like oh
you want to use a stylus you know here's
a few things that you might like to do
using it for everyday use you might have
previously used your fingers kind it
feels kind of weird to use it in place
of your finger so I'll put it that way I
mean it responds really well just like
your fingers do and it's not 2001 where
the stylus is like you know a necessity
to your phone and response times were
more like project chunky peanut butter
than project butter but it's an
accessory you know it's called the
Galaxy Note and it is a major marketing
feature for Samsung that you can use
this stylus but I just kind of use it
once in a while you know and I have fun
when I do and also PS the handwriting
recognition that it's straight up one of
the most impressive things I've ever
seen on a phone next to Google now it is
scarily accurate no matter how messy
your righty or Lefty handwriting may be
it's really really good so that
handwriting recognition is a plus in the
stylus by itself there's also even this
hover feature which is pretty neat so
you can hover over things without
actually clicking them that can reveal
what certain buttons do or you can have
it slide through previews of a video
clip to get to a clip you want to watch
or even content awareness so it knows
when it's hovering over a text box and
when it's not so all the stuff bundles
together in a stylus that fits neatly in
the side of the note out of the way if
you don't want it and it's called the
s-pen and right next to that S Pen in
the body is the second largest battery
in any phone coming in at 3100 milliamp
hours and I actually tried to kill it I
tried for a full day unsuccessfully
constant use six and a half hours of
screen on time 22 hours of being on I
tried so hard but it still wasn't dead
10% left at 11:25 p.m. so I called it
quits very very impressive long long
battery life on this guy so a couple
that battery life with super phone specs
a massive non pentile 5.5 inch 720p
Super AMOLED display buttery smooth
performance with Android 4.1 and a
bulging or pocket like no other you can
be proud to rock the Galaxy Note 2 which
is arguably the best phone you can get
right now so there you go guys that's
been my experience with the Samsung
Galaxy Note 2
overall this is absolutely a flagship of
a phone there's no question about that
it has a quad core processor Android 4.1
jelly bean LTE in the United States a
huge 3300 milliamp hour battery that
could last two days
with no problems the only thing about it
is the really large size and that would
make someone either consider it or throw
it down the drain but I think that you
can try it out and you can actually get
a better a sense of how big it feels in
person and you'll get used to it
I didn't think I was going to get used
to it at all I thought it would always
seem big to me but now this seems phone
size to me which is a little weird to
say but it makes the galaxy s3 seem
small which makes the Galaxy Nexus seem
really small which makes other smaller
phones seem mini as Samsung would
definitely agree so the choice is yours
go ahead leave a thumbs up on this video
if you want to see a more in-depth
comparison to its brother over here the
galaxy s3 I know a lot of people were
interested in both the similarities and
the differences so I covered a little
bit of that but if you want to see a
full video let me know if there's a
comments section if you want to talk
about this and either way that's been it
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the very next video which should
be one that you'll be really excited to
see so don't miss the next one